you and i
encountered something i will speak with
a bit obliquely for the moment
we encountered an analysis of where we
are with respect to covid that is
very challenging and the
i was struck by the fact that apparently
this analysis was pulled down from
youtube within two hours of being put up
now i expected um something
like what we ran into with pandemic and
judy mikovich where you and i separately
watched that video
and alarm bells were regularly ringing
about the analysis there were things
about it that were clearly
wrong there were also there was also
that video put out by the kern county
doctors
um early on which is different from
landemic but similarly when we did
we we did an analysis of it it just
nothing
didn't stand up nothing worked right now
in either case would
i and i assume you advocate that these
things shouldn't be viewable
right um both of those were also pulled
down and they should then they shouldn't
have been
right right um but this analysis that
we've uh
most recently seen is very very
challenging and i have to say i think
the assumption has to be that there is
something seriously wrong with it but
the person advancing
the analysis is very well credentialed
which
is also uh arguably the case in judy
mikovich's case
and the kern county doctors also had a
clinical
background so anyway you know these were
not uh
kooks with no position from which to
speak but in this case we've got
somebody who's really well positioned
and he makes a very interesting argument
which i will say i now think i know how
to test but
but here's the problem it was pulled
down from youtube
in two hours it is now viewable on
a blockchain-based video site that
effectively
protects it from uh you know from
interference of you know below a certain
level lbry
excited i don't think so but i'm not
sure
um in any case here's the problem we
have a youtube channel
that youtube channel is subject to
guidelines
that are impenetrable and unfollowable
to discuss this question um
for us to talk about for us to talk
about it leaves open the possibility
that google will decide we are over some
line some line that
we would obviously argue and most
certainly win the argument that the line
is nowhere near this that this is a
discussable hypothetical deductive
question that there are
proper tools to be brought to bear on it
but the fact is
there is no the guidelines themselves
are vague the there is no the community
guidelines of google
right there is no court in which you can
uh
plead your case the fact that the video
was pulled down in the first place says
that google has
taken up the opinion that a discussion
of this
because the presentation itself is
responsible
right it makes arguments that are
evaluatable um it suggests that google
uh takes a view that i would argue is
indefensible but there's nowhere to make
that argument
it suggests just like we were talking
about the beginning of the hour
that there is this vision of what
science is
in blue team's heads that
once we have an answer that we've agreed
on that is the truth
and no further evidence can possibly
take that truth off its pedestal because
that
is has always been will always be true
and that of course is not at all how
science works
so what we want to do what we have been
doing is
speak to the uncertainty and and weigh
evidence
and talk about what it would mean if but
in this case
it would be really really dangerous to
us it would it would be
dangerous and there is no mechanism to
figure out ahead of time
what comes of it right or you know what
line you know google can be wrong
about what the line is but it could be
specific about it so that we could say
the line doesn't belong here
but in the interest of uh continuing to
be able to talk about these things will
stay on the side of it but we there is
no line is the problem the line
is a judgment call to some uh
unaccountable
mechanism so here's the here's the
predicament
you and i were driven out of very secure
jobs by nonsense we are fortunate that
the tools
with which to architect a different uh
livelihood exists in the world right
we were able to you know we didn't have
to build a server
farm to serve videos to every corner of
the
world that thing simply exists you can
sign up you know build your channel the
tools uh you know to sell merchandise or
whatever all of these things are just
available there and that's a marvelous
thing to exist but the problem is
they are all subject to the veto of an
unaccountable authority
that delivers guidelines that you cannot
adhere to the only way to be anywhere
close to certain that your livelihood
will continue into next week
is to say so far basically to do the
bidding of those
who would control speech right you have
to stay away from anything
that could be understood you know and
maybe this is another
place to point it out the reason that
something like google
might decide that we can't have a
discussion about the validity or lack of
validity of this
expert's point about current covit and
its apparent resurgence
that has again to do with the difference
in analysis between
the individual and the collective in
effect what google is doing
is they are deciding that a discussion
of this will cause individuals to make
decisions
that are not in our collective interest
and so google has decided for us that
the way
to address that problem is to inflict
a conclusion as if it is absolutely
secure
so that the actual analysis does not
occur in public
so that nobody will draw what they
consider to be the foregone wrong
conclusion
right so all of that is google deciding
what the
answer to the question is and therefore
what people
are to do in light of it and this is
completely intolerable
heterodoxy does deal with all of these
ambiguities
it does deal with the difference in
level of analysis between the individual
level and the collective level
and there's a lot to be said about it
but what you know the world we are
living in is one where we are free to
make a living using tools provided by
google but we dare not disagree with it
about whether or not this can be
discussed in public
right and this is absolutely
preposterous and it raises all sorts of
questions as
your kundera passage does
now what does it have to do with
hitchens um
so the point is if as i was describing
this to a friend he pointed me to a
couple of quotes that come from
christopher hitchens actually we put the
first one up zach okay
oh boy all right it says the true
essence of a dictatorship is in fact
not in its regularity but in its
unpredictability and caprice
those who live under it must never be
able to relax must never be
quite sure if they have followed the
rules correctly
or not and that's christopher hitchens
from the book hitch 22.
uh you want to scroll down here's the
other quote
the essential principle of
totalitarianism is to make laws that are
impossible to obey christopher hitchens
from god is not great
so um i have a principle from long ago
which i call the low posted speed limit
yes yes you do um and the low posted
speed limit is a speed limit posted so
low that a reasonable driver will almost
certainly violate it and what this
allows you to do
is punish those you like so you you the
state you the state if
if you're you know a cop in a town with
a speed limit so low that everybody
violates it then you can pull over
gays or jews or long hairs or whoever
you don't like
right and the point is the law
does not read as if it is biased against
the law is not bigoted
right but it allows for bigotry to
flourish exactly and so the
arbitrariness and the caprice of the
um of the structure the fact that the
standard is set so low that enforcement
is perfectly arbitrary or can be allows
all kinds of things to happen
and the fact that hitchens connects this
to totalitarianism that he argues
that this is in fact a feature and not a
bug that in order to make
totalitarianism work
you have to constantly be looking over
your shoulder with the fear that you
have violated the rule even if that
wasn't your intent
because that thing can come back to
haunt you and uh
in in a dire manner that is what keeps
the thing
uh humming and to be to find that we are
facing this
in our relationship with these platforms
that are
frankly giving us all of these marvelous
tools with which we might otherwise be
you know upgrading our collective
understanding of things
but instead they're going to manage our
collective understanding uh
in ways that prevent people who do have
relevant expertise from
sharing it discussing its possible
implications falsifying it in public
right is uh is is absolutely disastrous
so it really is a third thing that
you've just said so your low p
your low posted speed limit principle
which is that you make a law which
almost everyone breaks
such that the enforcement of that law
allows
individuals who are tasked with
enforcing
to enact their internal bigotry or
whatever it is that's one thing that's
what you have said
um hitchens says um you make laws that
are impossible to obey which is
different from low posted speed limit
low posted speed limit is
you tend not to obey them um but you
could
yeah um he says totalitarianism is the
creation of laws that are impossible to
obey and then his third one the one we
started with
um is the unpredictability and caprice
of the rules such that you never know
this is where we started with regard to
can we talk about some of this possible
new covet discussion that's coming out
we don't know google google has not told
us the community guidelines are vague
presumably intentionally and this gets
to hitchens point
right that um it is the unpredictability
and caprice
and um effectively that is
it's certainly related to your low
posted speed limit but i think it's
distinct i think these really are three
distinct things all of which which we're
seeing in play
with things like the tech giants at the
moment who have
such remarkable control over not just
those of us who are creating and
producing content
um but you know all of us who are also
consuming content and having our
having the options before us changed by
hidden forces
uh that we cannot see nor into it um
and i would say you either cannot figure
out whether
something is uh is against the rules or
you can but only
putting your livelihood in jeopardy
which is not unlike what totalitarian
regimes do
you know you do something and you may
find yourself behind bars
you know and in this case i do want to
emphasize though there is something
uh hauntingly familiar from
these totalitarian regimes there's also
brand new stuff here
and one of my concerns is that because
and i actually did a little checking
because none of the phenomena which
carry the hallmarks
of totalitarianism or fascism
check all of the boxes right we are
going to persistently be
in this state where we see hints of
these things but we never cross the
final threshold there
because in fact the list of
characteristics that we
have been led to expect are based on a
historical
world that we no longer live in and so
you know we're not going to face fascism
again
of the same kind but we're going to face
something with those tendencies and very
different tools
and you know the worst thing here
is that one of the tools in a world of
platforms
using algorithms to enforce arbitrary
standards there is a tendency
both naturally because it's simple and
arbitrarily and politically because
it's expedient for each side to do it
there's a tendency
to say this is our team here's what we
believe
anything outside of that zone is the
enemy and
is to be dealt with as such which means
that the
the surface of that bubble now cannot be
penetrated with new information
or you know the stuff of upgrade right
it can't be because everything else is
viewed
as hostile and wrong and so i think you
and i
are continually tripping over this right
and
the stuff around unity being uh
suspended
at twitter and the stuff about me being
tossed off of facebook
has to do with the fact that these god
goddamn
algorithms don't know what to do with
heterodoxy because in general what they
encounter is people who
show themselves to be on one team or
another and if your litmus test for that
is
doesn't believe these things then lots
of us don't believe these things but we
also don't believe those things and so
the point is
you know your your algorithm's no good
here right
yeah the there it is heterodoxy renders
the algorithm incapable of figuring out
what you
are right you know you're a platypus in
a world where you've got
you know birds with bills and you know
mammals with fur
right and you know how much
harm are we doing to our collective
sense making
by virtue of stupid algorithms that are
looking to put us in too few categories
to deal with those of us
who frankly might have something
important to add to the conversation
but it's going to be you know
neutralized out of existence
yeah so we have talked um and your
brother has talked about
trying to be ash negative right to not
be the person who conforms to patently
false things that are being said in your
presence
be the kind of person for whom the
algorithms
of big tech and everyone else are no
good here
be able to say your algorithm's no good
here and figure out ways
to obscure yourself from it to hide from
it to evade it to move forward without
it seeing you
and i don't know what all of those ways
are at all but
um heterodox thinking is the way forward
not accepting an ideology
that has been handed to you by blue or
by red or by left
or right or whoever it is that if you've
accepted
an ideology because you agree with one
thing in it and assume that there for
everything else is true you are not an
independent thinker and you are very
likely to get conned
yeah you are very likely to get conned
as is right
um i i will say i'm struck
i know some people weren't all that into
us discussing clubhouse but
uh this platform this new platform that
is
still in beta but is growing in terms of
its population
is revealing to those of us who are
paying attention to it
why this is so difficult because inside
of this platform and again the platform
is all spoken word real time it's
synchronous you get into a room and you
have a discussion with people
many of whom you don't know but
there is a feature in which you can
block people
of course like every other platform but
those blocks have an
impact if somebody
who is in a position i think somebody is
a moderator in a room
where they've blocked you you can't see
that the room exists at all which means
that from the point of view of the
people in the room
there is a tendency for the conversation
to actually conform to a standard so to
the extent
that you know i might be disliked by
people who
are advancing the the blm banner
they may block me it means i can't see
the conversations they're having
i won't be present in those
conversations and they will have an
artificially narrow view
of the range of thought on this issue
because people who are heterodox
won't be there to to speak and so you
know
it's a damned if you do damned if you
don't problem they're trying to solve
one problem and creating what i think is
a much bigger problem
uh in so doing but you can just see that
people
i don't know the solution to that one
though i don't i don't think you can i
don't know anything about this platform
ever been on it but i don't think you
can have a social media platform
that doesn't allow you to block well you
could allow people to individually block
and then there's no way to stop such
sorry i missed something about the
you individually block but then the the
platform
infers from your block that you are not
welcome in certain spaces so you can't
even see that they exist
so instead of so it infers something
that in some case you know if you've got
a troll there who's just making trouble
sure right you can imagine that you
don't want such a person to show up in
that room but
by doing that you are creating power for
those who would block and in fact this
is an
analog for the system
that the other platforms have
established in which
they claim oh an algorithm flagged you
sorry right
why did the algorithm flag me oh because
a bunch of people reported you
why did they report you oh because they
viewed you as on the other side they
were doing a political job by reporting
you which then triggered the algorithm
which then allowed
the platform to decide what it thought
of you and it used the algorithm as an
excuse
yeah so your algorithm's no good here
[Music]